not for these they bump me on the hide
you so you make Dion's character sport
the mustache for this movie and you were
nicely clean yeah he had the porn I have
the clean [ __ ]
did you okay with that I was yeah you
know actually mustaches weren't big at
during that time and they and the the
whole makeup department we discussed it
they're very very very specific yeah
they're research but we felt like a part
of the the rebellious nests of this
character that he would rock among so
how it made him look really different I
mean the way the mustache it's he's
unrecognized yeah you're and it's more
of a porn 70s okay the car chase scene
has got to be my favorite since Peter
Yates directed bullet back and see the
car chasing dudes it's cool when you
talk about this and how amazing it was
to work on this scene alone well there's
a lot of piecemeal stuff you know what I
mean there's a lot of you you know your
storyboard it you put it together bit by
bit by bit by bit and you know you got
to have an actor who understands that
there's two seconds but that has to be a
moment of tremendous tremendous
intensity you know and Chris really got
that really sold the intensity of the
chase and you know we we put it together
with the help of a lot of good car guys
it's not guys visually this movie is
perfect it's stunning it's beautiful and
it really transport you transports you
back to the the era of course that's
what you were going for but how easy or
/ difficult was it to actually do that
well if I had had the true era cars
there were 18 horsepower so what I've
been like one of those like juice it up
to make it feel contemporary and
exciting for contemporary audiences but
by the same token I think if you're
driving one of those rickety old cars at
full speed it would feel scary you know
so I think it was the equivalent of that
why do you want to tell this story
I was until a great gangster story I
read the book and I thought this is an
incredible gangster story and I want to
tell it I want to do the cars I'm gonna
do the suits I want to do the guns I
want to the malls I want to have
gangsters I'm gonna have betrayal I'm
gonna have love I thought that was that
was the way to go these were the big
this was like the big Superman Batman
blockbuster of its day these old-school
gangster films exactly this used to be a
blockbuster this is what you know
Hollywood used to make as a blockbuster
no doubt about it
Seanna said that you were speaking with
this irish accent on set throughout the
filming and she says quote it was quite
funny um was it funny my eyes probably
funny hers was very good mine was
laughable I like the accent you used in
the movie with her when you like to see
this you get to attempt the Irish accent
no I didn't try I'm terrible at accents
and I was nervous doing a little bit you
know he's did a great job you know he's
he's the king of it so to do the Boston
next to him it's it was intimidating
yeah guys thank you so much great film